fortnite do you play fortnite's a
ranking
fortnite you play games
you ever played fortnite
i'm dead
foreign
[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome back to ask mkbhd number 27.
it's april and it's definitely getting
nicer out finally so we're going to take
advantage of that and shoot outside here
for a little bit
the phone's kind of trippy you're
probably familiar the shirt's also kind
of trippy that's new the link is below
and i asked you guys on twitter and in
the subreddit what you wanted to know
these are your questions so kareem wants
to know have you started training with
empire yet can't wait to meet you again
when you come to montreal yes so uh for
those of you who don't know the pro team
and ultimate that i'm playing for this
year is the new york empire our home
opener is tomorrow against uh toronto
rush but we play up and down the east
coast all season long so we'll play in
philadelphia in our home state of new
york we have ottawa montreal toronto and
washington dc if you're in any of those
cities i'll post a schedule below come
out to a game come say hi so ricky says
he recently put down a deposit on a
mission e congrats uh do you think
porsche evs will eventually supplant
tesla so the word supplant if you look
it up means to replace
and i don't think anyone's gonna be
replacing teslas anytime soon i don't
know what it is with this obsession
about like the tesla killer or replacing
tesla but a new electric skateboard
company can come along they don't
replace boosted their competition
a new camera company comes along they
don't replace canon we have canon nikon
panasonic all these guys so a new
electric car company can come along or a
new electric car can come along and not
replace tesla and they compete and at
the end of the day that's better for us
all right so we're seeing i'm seeing a
lot of questions about pixel 3 it's
coming out later this year we want to
know what that new camera is going to be
like what they do about the screen will
it have a notch so the thing i think to
remember with the new pixel which stems
back to the nexus days is it'll just be
no matter what the hardware ends up
looking like it's basically a vessel for
google's new software so google's new os
whatever i guess it'll probably be
peppermint but whatever the newest
android os ends up being google's new ai
their new software fixes all of that
stuff it's a showcase for developers and
us to use that software now it is nice
that at the end of the day we can buy
this phone and they do put some focus
into the hardware but i wouldn't be
surprised if it ends up looking a lot
like some other phones this year with
the exception of the camera we have this
new p20 pro and the review of this is
coming soon with three cameras on the
back and a lot of phones coming out now
have two cameras at least some more are
coming out with three but the prowess of
the pixel 2 and the whole success of
this phone which is the incredible
single camera is the fact that it did
all the things that you used to need two
or three cameras to do well in one it
did edge detection extremely well for
portrait mode photos it has great color
great dynamic range so having another
single camera on pixel 3 i think would
emphasize that it'll continue to do all
these crazy things with software on a
single camera so it won't look like
other phones in that way but i wouldn't
be surprised if it doesn't have a
headphone jack again if it has a notch
if it has a similar look to other phones
we've seen that would not shock me at
all it's still a vessel for the software
the only frustrating part about that is
it makes me want other phones it makes
me want the google play edition stuff
back it makes me want to see other
phones with that same pure fast updated
software experience i would love to see
a note 8 or a note 9 google play edition
i would love to see a huawei p20 pro
google play edition but that's never
going to happen so it's just frustrating
all right so which product has given you
the most value for the money i thought
about this for a little bit and my
answer
is the shark slider
s1
it's a slider it's a camera slider i buy
a lot of products but video gear tends
to be pretty pretty frequent
and i bought this many years ago so we
tend to we roll through a lot of video
gear we upgrade things all the time it's
kind of like when you rebuild the boat
after you replace all the parts is it
the same boat but this one slider i'll
try to give you the original date that i
purchased it
i haven't upgraded i've used it since i
got it many different cameras have been
on it many different other things have
passed through but that slider the shark
s1 has been amazing it shot so many
different subjects in so many different
ways and to be honest it's a super
simple tool it's not a motorized slider
it's just two rails and some weights and
just moves the camera back and forth but
that's something i've gotten over the
years a lot of value from right i like
this one so on dope tech i feel like
you're slowly killing the youtube
culture which is cheap and easy to make
by using super advanced equipment that
robotic arm is too expensive and rare
and the red cameras and gimbals
so
that's
kind of the point of dope tech so there
are a ton of other product reviews and
things where i'm evaluating a product
you might want to buy in videos and
that's fun but dope tech is actually
leveraging this audience that we have
here to get an inside look at bleeding
edge technology that you may never
otherwise be able to see
so like supercars robotic arms things
like that companies are actually willing
to open their doors and show them for
the first time
to dope tech to get you guys a look at
that so it's almost like the you want to
find the less common stuff you're never
going to buy that robotic arm but having
it in a video and actually showing it
with you is cool to see so that's dope
tech hope that makes sense and we also
have other playlists and other videos
and all the reviews of things that we'll
actually be buying but dopetech is just
your glimpse behind the curtain all
right so what other two color
combinations two color combinations do
you think are dope other than black and
red i have to pick two
uh i think
i think red red and gray
is pretty cool
um
i'll give a nod to
black and yellow
hey mkbhd what's the possibility of
having a port free device in the future
no headphones no charging port
completely wireless
actually do think in fact i'll say i
will expect this to eventually happen
kind of like the same way we're trying
to get rid of bezels now we end up with
a notch because there's certain
technologies that haven't worked their
way down yet and we can't completely get
rid of it but we will soon
same thing with ports wireless
charging's not that great yet some
phones have it but when you do get it
great you can get rid of the charging
port
we already got rid of the headphone jack
and there's really not that many other
ports on phones so i think you will see
a portless phone so teslanomics asks why
get the roadster if not the founder
series i can speak to that um so tesla
products for those unfamiliar the
founders series stuff is always maxed
out and also always red it's always a
founder series red which is not like the
most vibrant red so basically the short
answer is if you want to get any other
spec or any different color you don't
get the founders edition so even like
the the multi-coat red that is a lot
brighter and different from the founders
edition red i think looks better so you
can still get a maxed out car in a
different color
also it looks pretty good in that sleek
sort of a space gray look and i think
staying under the radar not getting a
red car might actually be better so yeah
i think
that's why you wouldn't get founders
edition so when are you going to link up
with the 368 crew in new york city we
need to see you in one of uh casey's new
tech tuesdays honestly i'm definitely
down tech tuesday seems like a great way
for a collab to happen so we can
probably do that sometime but either way
that's where i'm going to end it uh
thanks to the noise situation i think
we've also set a record for longest
record time to make this happen without
interruptions but that's okay thank you
for your questions if you have any
others feel free to drop them in the
comments section below i'll hang out and
answer some of those too uh but thanks
for watching talk to you guys the next
one
peace
that stuff so that'll be the focus of
the pixel no matter what it looks like
oh my god gets into the hardware but
it's not the main
but google's
but google's whole software prowess with
the pixel 2 that's too loud isn't it
but google's whole
it's when i like make a
sound which was the incredible camera it
was all
the only frustrating part of that is
that it makes me want other phones with
stock android
we just saw that truck go that way
all right so which
but i'll try to put the original date
it's the same truck again
are you lost
do you need a map
do you need a map the red camera is and
gimbal
what i feel like you're slowly killing
the
uh what other two color combinations do
you think are dope
uh so the roadster yeah if i want
i think we set the record for longest
longest uh
blooper reel
of all time that's a great place to do
that yeah i'm down